just like it was sunu and sanders last
year alan robinson have company on the
trade market this year
and i know this one hasn't gotten there
yet but i'm trying to get ahead of the
curve i believe that browns should trade
odell beckham jr i believe that things
went off the rails for the browns the
moment they acquired odell beckham jr in
that stunning first day of the league
year trade in 2019 and so far in year
two the year that it was supposed to be
better how about 10 targets for three
catches and 22 yards for odell beckham
jr in the first game against the ravens
now look
it was the ravens in baltimore what were
you gonna what i mean what are you good
but still if this guy's one of the top
receivers in the nfl
shireen we need to see more production
from odell beckham jr let's hear some
sound from odell beckham jr from earlier
today on both winning games and
producing neither of which the browns
have been doing much lately
you have to watch everything you do
everyone's always watching
you know if you don't have the same
reaction that somebody may like then
a story a headline or whatever can be
written about you so
yeah that's always tough that's just the
position i'm in i've i've helped
put myself in that position
by some mistakes and a lot of by what i
did on the field all the good things
that i feel like we often forget about
but that's just kind of helped put me in
this position where the spotlight is
always going to be on me right wrong and
different
and just know that that's something you
got to deal with i think once i get
you all the world everyone to understand
that i care
about one thing and that's
winning and producing
i think that you'll be able to see some
of the other actions
and look at it from a different
perspective than a perspective of a lot
of the names and attachments that have
been thrown on me in a way
i
have held out hope shireen that odell
beckham jr is maturing to the point
where he understands
that
with fame comes attention comes scrutiny
and that you can't pick and choose what
kind of attention you're going to get
the slogan that i've applied in the past
to him and other players is hey
everybody look at me
what the hell are you looking at you
can't get upset if people are obsessed
with you once you've injected yourself
into that that stream that jet stream of
fame
and i i he shouldn't be talking about at
this point it shouldn't be an issue and
i don't know what question he was asked
to get there but
this guy is at a point in his career
where
he needs to embrace the fact that he's
famous he needs to accept the good and
the bad that goes along with it he needs
to understand that this is just the
reality of the life that he is leading
and he needs to produce
and three catches for 22 yards is not
acceptable last year even with the
injuries he was dealing with and he had
that groin
core muscle hernia they never quite know
what to call it but he had over a
thousand receiving yards even though he
was plagued with an injury that first
popped up during training camp he's got
the potential to be really really good i
think the problem is teams know if you
can take away odell beckham jr it
creates extra stress and dysfunction for
that team and that dysfunction isn't
going to go away until beckham gets
traded
well and you go back baker mayfield and
odell beckham have talked about
chemistry repeatedly since the browns
acquired him and they said oh it's going
to be better this year during the off
season they work together
and now they're saying after week one oh
it's going to be better we just need to
work on it this isn't the point to work
on it if it's not good at this point
it's certainly not natural i just have a
hard time seeing them developing any
kind of chemistry so you the browns are
in a difficult spot spot as are the
bears because they have a decision to
make on odell beckham
it can he be the receiver they think he
can be that he was his first three
seasons in the nfl or do they need to
look elsewhere and move on from him to
me they spend too much tr time baker
mayfield does trying to target odell
beckham when he's not open i mean the 10
targets and the three catches tell you
that from from game one and yes it was
the ravens but they just try to target
him way too much and i think if he's not
there they have so many other weapons
they can spread the ball out i mean i
would argue they didn't give nick chubb
enough carries after the first quarter
the other day and they're trying to
force the ball
into odell beckham and yes i know they
got behind quickly
in all of that but you know they have so
many weapons i i think it's time for
them to look elsewhere and the most damn
neat thing to me is he's played seven
afc north games 21 catches 296 yards and
two touchdowns
and we know the afc north has some
really good defenses at least two really
good defenses that he plays but he has
not been good in those division games
and that's when you need to be at your
best so i don't see the chemistry coming
i don't see him being good against afc
north teams i think it's time for the
browns to see what they can get for him
same deal with alan robinson wait a
while
come trade deadlines somebody's going to
give you something very valuable for
odell beckham i would i would expect
it's almost laughable when you look at
the quote from baker mayfield today
about it on the chemistry the connection
the symbiosis between him and his
receiver i think it has to come
naturally we're working on that no
no
it has to come naturally period end of
statement full stop you can't work on it
it's either there or it's not and look
sharim
baker mayfield comes to cleveland takes
the town by storm he's the new lebron
james he's everything johnny manziel
wasn't that was the fascination of the
browns fan after the 2018 season so
freddie kitchens gets the job first
mistake second mistake you wedge the
square peg of odell beckham jr into the
round hole i think cleveland isn't big
enough for both of those personalities i
think they never properly connected i
think the coaching staff is part of the
reason for it it just didn't work
beckham wasn't committed to cleveland
beckham probably didn't want to be
traded to cleveland beckham probably had
a bad attitude about it from the get-go
and it all has felt forced it has never
felt natural what has felt natural is
odell beckham jr's endless desire to
play for the patriots you talked earlier
about
the patriots being a possible
destination for alan robinson i still
think the patriots are a possible
destination for odell beckham jr and now
that cam newton is there it makes it
even more sensible than it would have
been right after tom brady left you know
when tom brady left i thought well there
goes the obj to new england thing and
there goes obj to tampa because they
don't need him they got too many
receivers there but you know what with
cam newton looking like the old cam
newton i think the door opens up again
to new england because it was clear last
year when beckham talked about the
patriots as they got ready to play new
england that's where he wants to be
how much would you love to see that too
cam newton throwing to odell beckham
what a great matchup that way it would
remind me of tom brady when the year he
had randy moss and threw for the 50
touchdowns it was incredible and i could
see that happening again with cam newton
if he had odell beckham on his team and
you wouldn't have to force the ball
into odell beckham in new england it
wouldn't be like that they don't have as
many of those big name weapons who are
going to demand the ball like they do in
cleveland i just think that would be a
natural fit for for odell beckham to go
there and and bill belichick has shown
that he's great with stars like that
he's done it time after time after time
aside from a b last year the failed
experiment after one game but but he
does a great job with all those guys he
brings in like that and they seem to
excel there when they haven't excelled
elsewhere and it's time for odell
beckham to go and and to be the receiver
that he was his first three years
because he hadn't looked anything like
that since then and i know there's there
was the injury in there some questions
at quarterback there's all those things
but he has not lived up to his potential
because of all those things and i think
if he goes with a good offensive
coordinator in a good offense with a
good quarterback he can be the guy we
think he is which is one of the best
receivers in football
and we never really know what's going on
behind the scenes we base our
assessments on the things that we see
and hear and would we be stunned to know
that behind the scenes beckham wants out
would we be stunned to know that baker
mayfield would like him to be gone so
baker can just go back to
throw the ball to the open guy that's
what it should be it should not be force
it to odell beckham jr it shouldn't be
the randy ratio that the vikings once
used to to poor outcome just throw the
open guy this extra stress it's hard
enough to play quarterback without
having to get the ball to this guy
that's going to talk to the media about
why i'm not getting the ball and then
other guys are talking about getting the
ball no you just get the ball to the
open guy go get open and if one guy is
double covered triple covered i'm going
to throw it to someone else and i don't
have to worry about the guy who's double
covered complaining about it and uh
baker mayfield needs something shireen
because as someone tweeted last night
to significant approval on twitter you
have been hanging around me too long
i've corrupted you after only one day
the kind of tweet that i would be proud
of baker mayfield has more career
commercials than he has career wins and
that screenshot was taken when there
were only 4.7 000 likes the last time i
saw it at over 24 000 and that was a few
hours ago so you have touched the
collective nerve of the american
conscious and unconscious with that
tweet so sorry baker mayfield uh but
something needs to happen to turn that
guy's career around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports